[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia para hablar sobre
los falsos negativos en las pruebas de
kobe 19 esto es cuando el resultado de
una prueba no detecta alteración aun
cuando hay enfermedad en el paciente
doctor pérez gracias por esta
comunicación en el contexto de las
pruebas del gobi 19 que son los falsos
negativos
recordemos que las pruebas diagnósticas
pueden tener falsos negativos significa
que la prueba es negativa y la persona
tiene la enfermedad
eso sucede cuando el contexto de la
enfermedad por ejemplo se hace
tardíamente o se hace demasiado temprano
dependiendo de la prueba diagnóstica por
eso no es solamente una prueba de la que
diagnóstica con el nexo epidemiológico
la evaluación clínica la toma en el
tiempo preciso el bloquea el contexto de
que una persona tenga coi 19 y como son
las pruebas rápidas doctor se tiene
acceso fácilmente a ellas
las plagas rápidas son pruebas de
detección de anticuerpos estas pruebas
se hacen en una forma fácil y accesible
sin embargo tienen una limitación no
diagnóstica en el coronavirus
simplemente señalan si estuvimos
expuestos o no al coronario
por eso y las pruebas rápidas tanto las
palas moleculares no se hacen solamente
como parte del diagnóstico nosotros los
médicos evaluamos el nexo epidemiológico
las características clínicas el momento
de la infección para tomar la prueba es
decir que una prueba sin evaluación
clínica no es suficiente para el
agnóstico y la coidh 19 hay pacientes
que clínicamente tienen la enfermedad y
las pruebas son negativas pero sabemos
si tenemos la sospecha clínica la
tratamos como tal aquí el mensaje
importante es la evaluación médica no
solamente las playas' diagnósticas
sirven para el coronavirus es la
evaluación del médico con las pruebas
diagnósticas doctor y cuáles son las
pruebas que garanticen un diagnóstico
fiable
las pruebas dependen del contexto
clínico la evaluación médica y el
momento en que se toma no hay una prueba
diagnóstica perfecta se necesita siempre
tener un contexto para tomar la prueba
las pruebas moleculares se toman en la
primera semana y diagnostican si el
virus está presente las pruebas de
anticuerpos se toman tardíamente y
refieren si estuvimos expuestas al virus
es decir que la prueba diagnóstica sin
evaluación médica no es suficiente los
laboratorios del mundo han tenido que
trabajar a contrarreloj para la
elaboración de pruebas doctor como están
mejorando sus procesos en medio de esta
carrera
cada vez tenemos pruebas más accesibles
más económicas y que se pueden hacer
casi que en la casa en los domicilios
pruebas de saliva pruebas de sangre muy
sencillas para poder establecer quiénes
tienen o quiénes estuvieron expuestos al
virus en este par de meses vamos a tener
un gran avance en métodos diagnóstico
sobre todo en la situación de la
reactivación económica sin embargo no
supera la evaluación clínica que tienen
que tener si hay sospecha de la
enfermedad
para finalizar doctor ahora que se ha
conocido que el kobe 19 puede contraerse
dos veces significa que las pruebas
podrían no ser fiables
ojo con esto la demostración de que una
personalidad o kobe dos veces es en una
muy pequeña fracción de la población muy
pero muy pequeña y se tienen que hacer
estudios virológicos para determinar si
son virus distintos no se hace con las
pruebas de pcr si son positivas
persistentemente no hay que confundir
una secuela con una re inflexión es
decir que hoy para establecer que una
persona tiene un nuevo coronario se
necesita un proceso biológico extenso y
estudios que todavía no están
disponibles en todos los países por eso
debemos procurar cuidarnos mantener
alejamiento físico independientemente de
que ya hayamos tenido coke y la
probabilidad de infección siempre de ser
evaluada solamente por un médico experto
se debe tener cuidado al interpretar los
resultados de estas pruebas entonces
doctor carlos eduardo pérez le
agradecemos mucho su compañía e
información valiosa él es médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia y así concluimos estos cinco
minutos invitándolos a cuidarse mucho
del coronavirus y a que siga con
nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]